President Trump campaigned on a vow to
keep America from getting too involved
in foreign entanglements and now he
wants to make good on that promise in
Syria I want to get out I want to bring
our troops back home I want to start
rebuilding our nation we will have as of
three months ago seven trillion dollars
in the Middle East over the last 17
years we get nothing nothing out of it
but a number of military analysts
worried that would create a vacuum and
repeat the same mistakes they say
President Obama made in Iraq let's
discuss that with former former Green
Beret and congressional candidate
Michael waltz and former Army Military
Police Sergeant Chris Nayeem we thank
you both for being here thanks to you
for your service to our country I want
to note that Michael waltz was a the Fox
News and contributor but now since he's
a candidate for Congress he's not but
he's still joining us here here tonight
and and but first I want to start with
you I think the president's heart is in
the right is in the right place but is
it a smart move to Telegraph to the
enemy that we're going to bring our
troops up so Jason I don't necessarily
think he's telegraphic I think it's a
it's a jab he's throwing a jab to throw
out a trial balloon I mean certainly the
president doesn't think we should be
spending endlessly over over there and I
think that many of the experts many of
which I respect you know they didn't
necessarily get it on post-war Iraq
right and so the president doesn't want
us to be endlessly doing stuff over
there you know we've knocked out over 80
90 percent of Isis on the ground with
less than 2,000 troops so he's trying to
rebalance and get some of our allies to
pay their fair share as well so Michael
is is the president doing the right
thing is he gonna really truly bring all
the troops home now
well I think you put it well Jason that
as hard as in the right place in terms
of let's finish this thing and get to
and get the soldiers home but three
things are going to happen if we pull
out now it's too soon the president was
absolutely right to take the restrictive
our OE off and to focus on annihilating
Isis but if we pull out now one we're
gonna see Isis 3.0 the same conditions
that are there that led to Isis from al
Qaeda will lead to Isis 3.0 number two
our allies that we've been so reliant on
on the ground that has allowed us to
only have 2,000 troops on the ground
namely the Kurds and the Arabs will get
annihilated and if we do have Isis
reconstitute and start attacking Europe
in the United States again then it will
have a heck of a time getting us to
getting them to trust us and then three
will essentially abandon the region to
Iran but but Michael Mageau on in
perpetuity I mean to meet those
conditions are we gonna be there forever
well look I mean we've been in we've
been in Germany we've been in Japan
we've been in South Korea we have still
have 25,000 troops in Japan
unfortunately this president like with
South Korea is going to have to clean up
the messes that Obama left him after
eight years of just essentially turning
his back completely on the region and
it's going to take longer it's just too
soon at this point but he is absolutely
right in getting our allies to pay up
and to pony up and we ought to look at
what the bush el the Bush 41 did in the
first Gulf War where he had Germany
Japan and the Gulf allies contribute
over 50 million of dollars the president
has a huge huge work there to get the
Allies to pay for NATO's that abrasion
this might as any absolutely should do
that absolutely but but Chris at what
you know under what conditions when do
you actually bring the troops home well
I kinda think it's gonna happen
overnight I think the president's
signaling he wants to see more support
financially from those in the region and
it's - it's tough work I mean many of
those we served with in Iraq and
Afghanistan lost eyes lost legs fighting
wars where you know the post-war
reconstruction other things didn't work
and he's holding up some assets in Syria
but I think ultimately the president's
going to galvanize other supporters to
come to the table it's a chess match and
I think he's smart and some of our
senior advisors don't give him the
credit he deserves it's it's chess but
we've got to get other allies to do
things I think mr. Bolten is going to
have the president's ear we're gonna
have a good plan going forward but you
know we cannot just endlessly pay and do
all the work ourselves without having
others help us out it's not going to be
like Iraq and I think the president is
setting those expectations let me ask
you Michael first it should be a simple
question but I think it's one of the
most difficult questions what is victory
what is it
during in Afghanistan and what is
victory in in Syria in dealing with Isis
well I think Jason actually that's a
broader question what is victory against
Islamic extremism that's really what
we're dealing with and I think that
we're dealing with how do we undermine
and defeat an ideology much like we
undermine and defeated the ideology of
communism Syria Iraq Afghanistan those
are the battlefields of this modern
which i think is going to be a
generational war to undermine that
ideology because we're dealing with
brainwashing and we're dealing with
religion just as it took those other
battlefields and 60 70 years to defeat
the ideology of communism so that's
really what we're looking at and so what
does victory look like what it looks
like is when you have women marching in
Tehran and Riyadh and and Damascus and
where women thrive in civil society and
women thrive in politics you don't see
an extremist problem if that's what
we're really dealing with we are in a
global war against Islamic extremism and
these are just but a series of
battlefields that we have to win here
Chris how do you take what is victory
when you're talking to a 20 year old
who's going into battle leaving his
loved ones his family behind to go serve
the United States overseas how do you
explain to that young soldier or whoever
it might be and his family what is a
victory and what are you actually when
do you get to that point where you've
actually become victorious
that's a great question Jason well for
one and it's a topic for another time
we've got to get things right over at
the VA that's a whole other thing we've
got to get veterans able to see doctors
in a timely matter and get that right
but I think it's victory is when we're
able to see these attacks diminish when
we're able to see Isis that can't
function can't influence governments
over there and when our allies and we
come together with us and have a broad
coalition where US forces it's always
damned if you do damned if you don't
with the US military that's just the
truth in the Middle East and so I think
the victories we have we need to secure
by having our coalition governments that
we install do their fair share and take
control their futures so it's a tough
question to answer but that's what I'd
submit to you well as I think the spirit
of America is unlike anything else in
the world and you see it first and
foremost with our United States military
I thank you both for your for your
service and your
in your perspectives and and I again
thank you here tonight